i'm a big kung fu fan i love kung fu
movies i love martial arts in general i
think i saw my first martial art film
must have been a
a bruce lee
uh
compilation film called uh philly of the
dragon where he plays green hornet and
uh in a jim kelly movie called black
samurai double feature at the saint
george theater on staten island
new york and uh ever since then
i was geeked it was only it was only my
fourth movie i ever saw
my first movie let me say my first movie
i saw was uh tom sawyer
and then i saw star wars
the swarm
and then these two comfort movies
and then rocky the martial art films
just really took me away you know the
action
the brotherhood that it shows
uh
um and also some of the buddhist
contexts as i started to get older i
started understanding some of the
buddhist context
so um you know and um it became part of
my music as you know wu-tang clan and
now without going to the film world it's
my entry into the film world as a
director is the brain the action-packed
martial art movie that to me have some
elements of star wars in my film as well
you get a chance to see the film
you'll realize that you are in a place
that doesn't it doesn't exist even
though we are on earth
it's in a center village called jungle
village and it's really uh
you know an imagination place that's
full of fun i've directed videos and uh
maybe a couple of small self-financed
independent films that i've i have
the world has not seen yet
um but no this is my first
you know studio film where
a real big cruel professional cast of
actors
and everything and uh
you know a strong screenplay
so this is so i said i consider this my
first director of debut it definitely
was intimidating because you know you
have a act of that caliber
in your hands
you know that's like having a glass bowl
and he's a treasure for for his country
for the for hollywood itself and i can't
drop that glass bowl so i was being very
careful i didn't want i didn't want to
make no mistakes with him i didn't want
to put him in a situation that
you know he had so many fans around the
world i didn't want to put him in a
situation that he lose any fans based on
taking this role
but he trusted me as an artist
you know i mean and he knew that as an
artist that i do have good visions
and he came on board and and we had fun
you know i mean he was a little nervous
at first of course but i think if you
ever talk to him he would say we have
fun and we had a guy named byron mann in
the film as well um
and i think
him alone his personality and his
character alone
just makes made everybody feel fun you
know because he's a funny guy he's a
cool guy he plays a great character
called silver lion you have some movies
that's just hard hitting hand-to-hand
you have some that's like crouching
tiger where they're flying through trees
and
and i didn't want to go crouching tiger
um know that i want to stay on the
ground
so so we got a good balance i got corby
yoon corbin all the transporter movies
and so when you watch jason stadium does
do his movies and all those
all those touches and the bone identity
type of fighting
corby is the master of that but he's
also done all the gently early movies
like funk ceo and and once more time in
china and we even had some of jed lee's
crew with us on the on the set so we was
able to mix both of these worlds whereas
you know you have
uh you know modern martial art mixed
with classic short brothers martial art
mixed with some of the uh
woo
shoe as they call it in china uh flying
in the air martial arts but then also uh
when you got a guy like kung li in the
film who's a real mma fighter he's a you
know ufc fighter a world champion
world-class fighter
you're getting real things happening you
know you're getting a real scissor kick
done by a man who can do it to you in
real life when you got a wrestler like
dave bautista you know who who fights in
the ring and knows all the sioux flexes
and all the body slams and we get a guy
like him to come and bring some of that
to our film you get that
extra energy in this movie and that's
what this film has it has a collage of
things
and then when you get something like
russell crowe who's a gladiator
you know
you know his fighting style is not he's
not doing like you know
no bruce lee no he's doing gladiator
he's he's whipping you up he's not here
to play
it was it was some danger you know i
mean even even some of the stunt men had
to pull out and back out of things
you know what i mean say no we can't we
can't do it you know
um it's too dangerous
you know there's a there's this because
we didn't it's not a lot of sea it's
very small cgi in this film so
everything had to be done practical
so if this person have to run and jump
off that
balcony and and land on top of this
guy's shoulder
you know we have to figure out a way to
do it you know because it's not going to
be cgi
and we did it and um you know people got
hurt you know
people went to the hospital at least uh
you know out of nine weeks at least
twice a week
but
i will respect the chinese crew
the they kept a lot of information away
from me not to worry me
you know so it was it was like maybe
like
six weeks into the shoot when i started
pushing the guys harder because i had to
get my shots
and uh and then a.d pulled me to the
side said bobby we all love you
but we don't want to tell you but
god's been going to the hospital almost
every day on this thing and you have to
you know take it easy
and i said oh i didn't know if you you
know tell me he said i said so i said
you know what
i don't need that shot
yeah i mean i achieve at least 85
percent of my vision you're not going to
get everything like i said cause some
stuff is dangerous uh some stuff that
was up is impractical you know it's
better to go cgi
but um but uh
you know like i had a great
crew of people you know my asian team we
have 400 people of cast and crew
together
and the stunt team cory yoon is is one
of the best he brought on some other
guys to help out when he got too crazy
we actually flew in a team from beijing
that worked on the karate kid as well
and there's a bunch of kids that um that
um you know they they are they are a
stunt team it wasn't part of our
team i i i found them on the internet
and because it worked in karate kid and
i was like well this is hire these guys
to play the whole hyena clan
so this way we don't have to worry about
actors and things and they flew in
about 15 of these guys and all they do
is stunts all day
and uh and they they train about three
or four days and we got a great great
scene out of them i didn't do this i did
the score um i was i was forced to do
the score though
you know you know everybody said you're
a musician but you should do the score
but this was fun this was this was very
fulfilling for me
you know they have a great cast a great
kill a great cast a great crew
um
a great script you know me and eli roth
sat there and he wrote a great
screenplay together
some great producers you know quentin
tarantino mark abraham eric newman have
all that energy come together and me to
be the captain kirk of the crew
you know
i really feel like i actually took
myself
to a place that no man has gone before
and uh it was a lot of fun well i've
composed over 10 films already so i've
learned um the hollywood style like a
posing so we mix the hollywood style
uh we do have some asian sounds in our
film but we also know that i'm a hip-hop
guy so we got to have the hip-hop
element so this is a mash-up of also of
of sound
the same way as the same way that this
um cast is diverse
you know where you have an asian actor
you have a white actor a black actor you
have a brazilian actor in dave batista
you know you have females you have
koreans you have chinese you have all
these different people um
the same thing with the music is very
diverse
we have um
music from black keys
music from kanye west
where's khalifa my chemical romance you
know rock and roll guys
um as well as sally yay you know who
does john woo movies a famous uh chinese
singer
um and then we also have you know my
buddy howard drawson he's a trained
musician trained composer
and we wrote a lot of different cues or
i would write like a a piano line and
he'll hear it and go great line bobby
but what if um i take that line and have
the french horn play it
and so we was able to take a lot of
different lines and change it to fit the
fit the scene and one thing i think we
did that was so cool for me was
we went and got some of wu-tang
original songs the masters you know sony
gave them gave them to us to use and we
took out a lot of stuff that was in it
and we re-orchestrated it
you know
and then stacks you know the famous
label stacks
stacks also came on board to help us out
and they gave me about 10 of their
famous stats queues like you know songs
from william bell from isaac hayes from
mabujon and we was able to take these
songs strip them down and re-orchestrate
them so this is you're going to have a
great time
listening to this movie as a soundtrack
i actually uh
personally actually have the soundtrack
of all my cues it's about 70 different
music shoes in this movie 70.
and i put them on while i'm working out
and it's a it's a great ride you know
and you kind of get your own movie in
your head so i think the score will be
released also commercially and i think
the score will will be very satisfying
as well as a movie the man with the iron
fist a film
that's designed for big screens for fun
and popcorn and let's go november 2nd
release date
you